last time you were here you showed this
picture from you you you did something
for something out live where you played
Aziz Ansari but it never made it on the
air and so you brought the picture here
was you dressed as Aziz I think we have
it right there you I'm told that you you
you recently dressed as Lil Wayne or at
some point recently you dresses little
Halloween Oh Halloween last year okay so
about a year ago you dressed as Lil
Wayne that I did not know about you seem
to like to dress up as men petite men
who hang out with Kanye that's like my
thing now I yeah well mostly it's
because I'm super lazy and it's like the
easiest Halloween costume ever it's just
like a red hat a wife-beater baggy pants
and like a grill oh and a sharpie to
draw the tattoos right so it was easy to
throw together I think we have a picture
bring a picture of you is there you oh
there you go Lil Wayne Callies
but here's the thing that's not little
Wayne's resting face no I was gonna say
I that it's not the Lil Wayne I know
that it's not the little Wayne let's do
side by side that is the Lil Wayne
expression his picture looks like
someone just showed him my picture
edging on really bummed out yeah yeah